in an interview over the weekend former
New York City Mayor and president
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani suggested
to NBC's Chuck Todd the truth isn't
truth now the left which increasingly
denies the existence of objective truth
is clutching their pearls they're
shocked they're horrified but we will
explain what Mayor Giuliani meant and
what truth means to Democrat politicians
and operatives spoiler alert it doesn't
mean the truth then a White House aide
is fired for being a white nationalist
even though there's no evidence that
he's a white nationalist drooling Joe
Kennedy defends an illegal alien who is
wanted for murder in Mexico sounds about
right
it sounds in keeping with the Kennedys
suspected weeble brian Stelter eggs on
Jack Dorsey to jack up censorship on
twitter and the best photo on the
internet will be presented on this is
America
finally important life advice on a new
segment that I like to call how to be a
man when you look like a Maddow
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
we've got too much to get to today way
too much to get to so before we do any
of that look if you're watching or
listening to this show the chances are
you watched some pretty weird stuff on
the internet
huh you watched some things that
probably you wouldn't want to get out
that's why I got to thank Express VPN
because you've got to protect your data
and your information on the Internet
you've all of the recent news about
these big tech companies selling your
data they're testifying before Congress
right now if you just make an online
purchase or simply access your email you
could put all of your private
information at risk and these days with
our insane political climate I'm only
half joking when I say your political
information on the internet could really
mess up your life or your reputation or
your job or whatever you're being
tracked online by social media sites
marketing companies and your mobile or
Internet provider they don't have your
best interests at heart which is why you
need to take back your privacy with
expressvpn it has easy-to-use apps that
run seamlessly in the background of any
computer phone or tablet turning it on
takes one click it secures it and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your IP
address you can protect yourself for
less than seven bucks a month I'm
telling you don't be a cheap idiot it is
seven bucks a month is like nothing and
the the value is so great you should not
be browsing the internet without
protecting your data do it with
expressvpn it works wonderfully very
well seven bucks a month by the way
don't say I never did nothing for you
get three months free at expressvpn com
slash michael mi CH AE l exp or ESS VPN
comm slash michael mi CH AE l three
months free with a one-year package
expressvpn comm slash michael to learn
more let's get right into it I want to
talk about truth being truth because
conservatives are getting this wrong the
left is especially getting this wrong
what is truth is truth truth mayor
giuliani take it away you believe this
is on them that you would have that you
guys have not delayed the interviewing
delay the negotiation yes each time by
three or four days so we could write a
letter in response they have taken two
to three weeks to get back to us so I
what I have to tell you is look I'm not
going to be rushed into having him
testify so that he gets trapped into
purging and when you tell me that you
know he should
because she's gonna tell the truth he
shouldn't worry well that's so silly
because it's somebody's version of the
truth not the truth he didn't have a a
conversation this crowd I don't mean to
go like I know it isn't truth truth
isn't truth the president itíd state
says I didn't truth is a truth mr. mayor
do you realize what I know don't do that
don't do this to me don't doctors right
Donald Trump says I didn't talk about
Flynn with Comey Comey says you did talk
about it so tell me what the truth is
Don the gamma if you're such a genius
John McGann John McCain doesn't know if
that's the kitchen if they have two
pieces of evidence Trump says I didn't
tell him and the other guy says that he
did say it which is the truth this isn't
even that inarticulate I know that
they're trying to play it that way like
Oh crazy Giuliani there he goes again
this isn't even that inarticulate
certainly the phrase truth isn't truth
taken out of context is absurd it sounds
like Pontius Pilate talking to Christ
but that's why we need context what Rudy
Giuliani is reacting to is Chuck Todd
saying well that's the truth it's the
truth it's the truth and what Rudy
Giuliani is saying no man you guys are
spinning the truth you and the Democrats
and the and the forces that are trying
to attack President Trump there are two
there are two narratives here and the
question that Rudy Giuliani is asking is
who is Muller gonna believe his pal
James Comey or President Trump where is
the truth who's going to get hit with
the truth how are people gonna bend the
truth how are the mainstream media going
to bend the truth that's what's
happening they're trying to turn Rudy
Giuliani into Pontius pilot or some
Orwellian figure this is absurd here's
how you know this is absurd because the
left denies objective truth but Aleph
denies it these days this is why the
Daily wire exists as because we say that
facts don't care about your feelings
because the left says there's no such
thing as objectivity you had those
teachers in Massachusetts just a couple
of weeks ago they said we're going to
objectivity is a dangerous weapon
against social justice there is no
objective truth it's all subjective it's
all about feelings the right is the
group that says politics has to rely on
objective facts and objective reality
and the left
no it's that's from your point of view
that's your white privilege
that's your invalidating our experiences
no it's just interest groups butting up
against one another that is absurd and
what rudy giuliani is doing is calling
attention to that absurdity in that
abuse of truth this isn't I mean they
got they got him right this is an
example of Chuck Todd having that gotcha
moment and that's the headline that has
becoming a meme just like Chuck Todd
says but the point that Rudy Giuliani is
making is actually the opposite of that
and it's very important that's an
important point for him to be making
because in this case the left is not
interested in the truth Chuck Todd says
well when it comes to the mall or
investigation it's just the truth right
it's just the truth okay if you're
interested in the truth Lefty's muller
investigation resistance impeachment
squad if you're interested in the truth
how come we haven't looked at that
Clinton email server why did Hillary
Clinton wipe her entire email server how
come we haven't looked at that DNC
server how come
Paul Manafort is indicted but Tony
Podesta isn't indicted how come the only
trial that's come out of this
investigation is against Paul Manafort
for alleged crimes he committed long
before the Trump campaign and a crimes
which basically amount to buying nice
suits how come the 2016 election isn't
being brought up in the trial of Paul
Manafort how come Donald Trump isn't
being brought up how come Russian
interference in the election isn't being
brought up if you're so interested in
truth where are the investigations of
the Democrats where's Tony Podesta who
worked with Paul Manafort but Tony
Podesta is a big Democrat he's a big
Democrat operative so he doesn't get
pulled in Hillary Clinton she gets off
the hook Hillary Clinton destroyed
federal Records mishandled federal
record records clearly engaged and paid
to play though I suppose we'll never
have the proof for certain because she
wiped her email server we're the
investigations there it's just the truth
right isn't it just the truth no the
Democrats and the the left here are not
interested in the truth they're
interested in taking down Donald Trump
which is a great point that that
regionally on his making she's saying no
no no the thing that you're calling the
truth here that's not the truth which is
why we have to be careful what Chuck
Todd is trying to do is lure the Trump
legal defense lawyer Giuliani lure the
president into playing a game on an
honest playing field when they are
playing dishonestly
they say no no we're just gonna we'll
treat you fairly no we'll treat you
fairly well we've treated you fairly so
far haven't we there's no evidence of
that it's been horrifically unfair it's
going on and on and on it's extended
well beyond its purview well beyond its
legitimate right to investigate and it
we see no end in sight why would we play
fairly that's what he's talking about
and they're examples of this all over
the place the mainstream media are are
so complicit in this that we cannot when
they say oh it's just the truth we
should always be extraordinarily
skeptical and not buy it for a second
consider this story over the weekend of
this illegal alien Joel aronia Laura
so Joel aronia Laura there was big
headline every mainstream media source
covered this immigrations enforcement
ice arrested a man an immigrant or a man
while he was driving his pregnant wife
to the hospital those monsters they they
were probably targeted him because his
wife was pregnant that's probably the
implication of these articles isn't it
the every handle I mean everywhere was
New York New York Times a USA Today
Washington Post everyone writing about
how ice targets man arrests man while he
was driving his poor pregnant wife to
the hospital okay that's the headline
they don't by the way they usually fail
to mention that he's an illegal alien
he's not an undocumented immigrant he's
not a future American he's not a
dreaming dreamer sleepwalker I guess
they're sleep walkers no is the illegal
alien who clearly committed a crime but
that's not the best part
the best part is he's wanted for murder
in Mexico they don't they've left that
part out of it didn't they they left
that part out of the reporting so this
guy Joel aronia Laura it was according
to ice targeted and arrested because
he's wanted for murder in Mexico here's
Joe Kennedy Joe Kennedy the third he
tweeted about this he said there's
heartless and then there's whatever the
hell this is
it's heartless right so you have the
media put out the ostensibly true
headline man arrested driving wife to
hospital that is sort of true but it's
actually a lie because it leaves out the
most
information which is that he was wanted
for murder in Mexico and that he's an
illegal alien who broke our laws so it
the the statement on its own out of
context that statement is true in
context it's an utter lie he says that
and so the mainstream media put that
headline out there and then the Democrat
politician tweets and says this is awful
and uses it as campaign fodder and this
is the cycle that they use because
they're working together because the
mainstream media or the communications
wing of the Democratic Party if you
don't remember by the way Joe Kennedy
and he's sort of a minor figure in
politics he was the guy who gave the
response to the State of the Union
address last year here is Joe Kennedy
just to jog your memory from that speech
still you Thomas a new charter photo
steadies a no that's why messiah hod
vamos a lahar vamos vamos vamos not not
the best Spanish accent not the best
command of the language but total
pandering right total pandering to the
left and they don't tell you that they
don't tell you that the guy was wanted
for murder according to ice the wife
denies the charges this is another
headline that's grand the wife denies
the charges that this man is wanted for
murder in Mexico she denied the charges
by the way in Spanish this was noted in
a couple of the reports CBS News talked
to her and they said the woman in
Spanish denied that her husband is a
murderer and this is good advice to
illegal aliens if illegal aliens want to
avoid being arrested or deported or
found targeted for crimes that they
committed in Mexico learn English
learning English helps this is a good
thing
there's nothing racist about that
there's nothing bigoted about that when
you go to a country you should know the
language of that country and you should
make an effort to learn that language
when you get there because consider the
flip side of this consider how many
illegal aliens there are in this country
I don't know if this man's wife is also
an illegal alien but consider all of the
illegal aliens in this country who flout
their illegalities out their crime and
are not arrested for it I was at an
event in Orange County I went to see Ann
Coulter down there and there was a big
protest by illegal aliens and they had
big shirts I said I'm an illegal alien
they didn't use that they said I'm an
undocumented future whatever that
whatever and there were cops are
there and they didn't get arrested
consider that because you know they're
the mainstream media and the Democrats
are trying to paint this image that
America is this heartless country
ripping fathers away from their pregnant
wives and yada yada yada people
regularly go on camera they say I am
here illegally I am committing a crime I
am using taxpayer resources hahahahaha
poking American citizens in the face and
nothing happens to them we are so lacks
when it comes to our enforcement we are
so generous we are so charitable only
it's only these egregious cases really
where ice axe you know you've got a man
wanted for murder and they act and
Democrats wring their hands and try to
portray law enforcement as the bad guys
try to portray American citizens as the
bad guys I hope they keep it up because
this is a losing issue including among
Democrats all of the polling shows that
this is a losing issue certainly among
Republicans independents and the
majority of Democrats so keep it up guys
but that that is that is just you got to
pay attention to these things which are
in very narrow out of context situations
true but they reveal major lies of the
left in the mainstream media another one
is the censorship issue so we've been
talking about this now for weeks big
tech is censoring conservatives they
start out censoring the conspiracy
theorist shirtless vitamin salesman then
they move on to people who appear on Fox
News then they move on to who's next who
is next they tell us that they're not
censoring Jack Dorsey the head of
Twitter he says we're not censoring
people based on their content here he is
sitting down with suspected weeble brian
Stelter are we doing something according
to political ideology or viewpoints and
we are not period we do not look at
content with regards to political
viewpoint or ideology we look at
behavior and we use that behavior as a
signal to to add to relevance we need to
constantly show that we are not adding
our own bias which I fully admit is is
left is more left-leaning and I think
it's important to articulate our bias
and to enter and to share people with
share it with peoples that people
understand us
but we need to remove all bias from how
we act and our policies and our
enforcement people have these
assumptions that that you're out to get
them or something this you know I feel
bad
comparing brian Stelter to weebles
wobble but they don't fall down that
isn't that's not a nice thing to do I
really mean that I'm sorry to do that
but he gets me so frustrated because
there is brian Stelter pretending
sanctimonious high-minded brian Stelter
and he is begging jack dorsey to censor
conservatives and he's he's denying what
is right before all of our lying eyes
he's there he's sitting there he goes
you know people think that you're out to
get them can you imagine that go on Jack
come on why would they think that was
those rubes those idiots
there's another clip of brian Stelter
later on he they're talking about the
alex jones banning and he says well you
know this and that listen i guess
yeah but jones won't change his behavior
will he he's not gonna change his
behavior
hmm the implication being you you should
ban him you should ban all of these
people that i disagree with or whatever
and and jack listen to what Jack said
it's pretty telling he says we don't
look at content we don't look at the
political content of somebody we look at
behavior yeah the the only behavior you
can have on Twitter is content content
is behavior on Twitter right the [ __ ]
you're the only you could just post
things that's it post or like things on
Twitter you're what you post is the
content so he's saying no we don't look
at content we just look at content we
don't look at content we just look and
actually he's sort of right they don't
really look at content they look at
people they look at the content broadly
produced by people which is why he
defended Alex Jones he said we're not
gonna ban Alex Jones he hasn't violated
our Terms of Service then for a few days
he got a ton of pressure from the left
what did he do he's suspended Alex Jones
what about Gavin McGinnis what what rule
did Gavin McGinnis break he just doesn't
they just don't like him they just so
even if it were true we don't look at
content that might be true what's worse
is that they look at people they just
look and they say yeah you're a
conservative or a hero in the case of
Alex Jones you're a vitamin salesman we
don't like you
we're gonna get rid of you that's what
they do the there are these these very
narrow truths that tell giant lies this
brings us to this White House
speechwriter you might have seen this
over the weekend a White House
speechwriter and policy aide Darren
Beattie or Beatty was fired the reason
he was fired is that he gave a speech at
the Menken Club conference in 2016 and
the media are reporting this as a white
nationalist conference and he's a white
nationalist and he's a racist and
they've got to get rid of him and bTW by
the way has said I I you can read my
speech my speech doesn't have any racism
in it at all I stand by my words there
I'm not a racist you have no evidence
that I'm a racist and I'm not going to
quit the pressure was too great and the
White House just fired him I would like
to correct the record on this though a
little bit because I listen to and read
a lot of them and can club writings and
speeches when I was writing a piece a
couple years ago on the alternative
right so I do know a little bit about
the Menken Club it's named after HL
Mencken the satirist pretty good writer
a slightly racist fellow a little bit a
little bit of a bigot but it isn't a
white nationalist conference that you
couldn't really call it that the founder
of it is a Jewish guy so who attended
yeshiva university so it's not quite a
white nationalist conference though they
do hold hands with those guys Richard
Spencer has gone to this conference I
think he one year or more than one year
he was the master of ceremonies they you
know that they also deal with people at
these conferences who are they've sort
of just gone a little too far
they've gone a little unsavory you know
Bill Buckley kicked them out of the
National Review or something people like
Peter Brimelow or like John Derbyshire
people who have made off-color remarks
or outright racist remarks and and so
they've been sidelined a bit they do go
to this thing you also have people who
haven't done that who are there so it's
a little bit murky but to call it a
white nationalist conference just isn't
true I think really the unifying
characteristic of all of them is they're
these extraordinarily contrarian paleo
conservative types they're just ornery
angry mostly white guys and Derbyshire
who spoke there who used to write for
National Review he's math
titian wrote wrote a pretty racist piece
on takis magazine but he what unites
them is their disdain for the
conservative movement so Derbyshire
complained in a speech he said that the
conservative movement just became about
tax cuts and fretting over fetuses so
you see this kind of very angry
dismissive aspect to the the Menken club
not terribly religious very old old
right but you again and I'm I'm trying
to be as fair as I can to them they do
let in people like Richard Spencer's so
there is that aspect to it but to call
it a white nationalist conference is not
totally fair that said if I were this
guy Darren Beatty baby would I speak
there no I wouldn't speak there knowing
what the Menken Club is and now also
that said look even I and I broadcast
from the broom closet of the ben shapiro
show i get a lot of speaking invitations
and you don't really vet these things
you just say okay well okay i'll go to
Texas or I'll go to this or whatever and
you don't really pay a ton of attention
so it's perfectly possible that this guy
went to this conference not knowing that
Richard Spencer was going to be there or
something like that that's it I wouldn't
have done it it's a little it's a little
dodgy it's a little they hold hands with
these racist types and so that that's
not a great thing should have been fired
for it I don't know should you know is
he a racist there's no evidence of that
did the media misreport this yes okay
that's all way of Prelude because well
we have this sort of dodgy Club where
they gave a speech you give a speech on
the intelligence in the right there are
some racist people in the room that's
not good
meanwhile the mainstream media in big
tech are defending outright blatant
racists enough and with nothing with no
problem whatsoever
uh-uh I'm trying to give a fair shake to
the critics of this guy Darren Beatty
for appearing at the Menken Club and
also to Beatty and not say he's a racist
if he isn't a racist I'm trying to be
honest about this what they do is they
defend out-and-out racists consider
Sarah John Sarah you know Sarah drunk
she's on the Editorial Board of the New
York Times now she's that
asian girl who hates white people and
talks about how awful white people are
and they need to go extinct and she says
she hates white men and they need to
cancel white people and all that the New
York Times was presented with all of
this they stood by her they said she's
an honor editorial board she represents
what we think she represents what we
want so when all of this came to light
Sarah John did not have a checkmark on
Twitter which used to be verification
but now it's a validation because it
just basically says who Twitter approves
of or likes or whatever it's not really
about who the person is anymore
for instance Richard Spencer lost his
check mark he didn't lose it because
he's no longer Richard Spencer he lost
it because he's a kind of a neo-nazi so
Sarah Jong tweets all these awful things
they come to light so what happened did
Twitter ban her from Twitter must have
right they're banning Alex Jones banning
Gavin McGinnis surely they ban stare at
John Wright no they gave her a check
mark it's just gay they said Oh Sarah
I'm so I can't believe listen we've
heard you public we have heard you what
Sarah tweeted we hadn't seen that before
and in light of those tweets we should
reward her great job we should cancel
white people they should all go extinct
that is what they're saying that's what
they're saying with this out-and-out
racists defending about Shannon Johnson
this is one that I sort of found I'd
like to take a little bit of credit for
this I think it had been floating around
the internet but I got her to delete her
tweets Annika Johnson tweeted out quote
this is a CBS News producer verified
check mark on Twitter as she's tweeted
these things quote now the white women
can't keep their hands off our men so as
they continue to make mixed babies the
white man will cease to exist
pow lawl next one so many women black
Hispanic and Asian Americans in Senate
and Congress now middle-aged white men
are slowly becoming minority beautiful
and then the third one the one that I
found today that she just deleted and
unfortunately I didn't get a screenshot
F white America F white America but
without the f with the word instead of
the F that's what she tweeted she has
her Twitter account she's verified she's
employed by CBS News so you're talking
about this guy this speechwriter who
maybe shouldn't have gone to this
conference because the conference plays
with some unsavory people
and okay I totally yeah okay I totally
grant that CBS News and the New York
Times are employing out-and-out self
self de self outed self showing
themselves to be what they are racists
they're just out there they're right out
there and there's no kickback for this
I've got a hurry but we've got so much
more to get to today another another
great example of the truth being hidden
hidden like like the frosting inside a
cake is this version of Jack Phillips
this guy you've heard this case of Jack
Phillips he's the Baker who didn't want
to cater a gay wedding and so this gay
couple sued him all the way up it went
up to the Supreme Court collar with
state of Colorado said you have to do it
forget about your religion no one cares
about your religion goes all the way up
to the Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court found that his First Amendment
rights had been violated his rights to
speech and his right to religion have
been violated by this political lobby
that wants him to make gay wedding cakes
so the same day that the Supreme Court
agreed to hear his case another guy
calls up and he says I want you to make
a cake which is blue on the inside and
pink on the outside to celebrate my
transition from being a man to a woman
I guess he's he's a man who thinks he's
a woman and he's going to to take
hormones and remuda late himself for
something to do that and he wants Jack
Phillips to participate in that
celebration so Phillips says no I don't
want to do that thank you very much I've
died I don't specialize in those cakes
and I'm not going to do it and of course
then he's being harassed by his
government again an obvious setup right
of course and the headlines are Jack
Phillips under fire again
God what a bigot this guy is as though
Jack Phillips is the only Baker in the
state of Colorado yeah
this guy man are there is there no other
cake shop in these in these states I
don't I don't think it appears that way
so how does late-night deal with this
he's obviously being targeted by these
insane political activists on the Left
they're trying to ruin his life they've
made him fire half as employees he's
lost 40 percent at least of his income
so how is this being played has this
being joked about on late-night Jimmy
Kimmel take it away or case after you've
refused to make a wedding cake for the
same-sex couple well he's back in court
because of another cake he doesn't want
to bake Jack Phillips filed a lawsuit
against the governor of Colorado this
time over a gender transition cake it
was blue on the outside and pink in the
middle and somebody wanted to have this
cake the Colorado Civil Rights Division
says he has to bake it for them and he
doesn't want to which is really funny
because this is a guy who spends all day
every day meticulously designing flowers
out of icing his whole life is gay
okay the cake might might bring that to
life or what and I will add this is Jack
Phillips the totally straight cake Baker
you would think that someone who looks
like the Reba McEntire version of
Colonel Sanders would be more
sympathetic to gender identity issues
he's gay get it do you get it he's gay
ha ha it's funny to be gay because it's
because according to Jimmy Kimmel it's
bad to be gay that's why it's a joke
right because it's bad to be gay and
that and he's gay
ha ha ha ha ha that's the joke so this
one I don't really get Jimmy Kimmel
keeps putting his foot in his mouth on
this he did this with Sean Hannity he
was arguing with Sean Hannity on Twitter
and he said Hannity you're gay and then
all of his fans said wait a second it's
ok to be gay I thought Jimmy you're on
the left and we on the left have been
talking about how it's okay to be gay
and now you're saying it's bad to be gay
I don't doesn't quite make sense it's
such an easy joke and it's so but it's
so bizarre because if Jimmy Kimmel's
whole premise is that it's it's gay
marriage is a wonderful thing and the
state should force you to participate in
gay weddings and being a man who thinks
you're a woman and then you're gonna
make yourself look more like a woman
that's a great thing in the state should
force you to participate in those
celebrations
then why would being gay be an insult it
doesn't really make a lot of sense does
it but he does this all the time and
it's so cheap I mean why can't this
Baker just like do his job can't he just
like go on with his life why did it wide
why is the left so insistent on forcing
people to do what they say because
that's the that's the inherent nature of
the left it gets down to this what's the
truth truth isn't truth truth isn't
truth when there is objective truth you
when people recognize
when they can speak openly about truth
they don't have to coerce you into
following their desires they don't have
to coerce you into doing what they say
they want to do going along with their
fantasies because there's the truth and
we can see the truth but the left
doesn't believe in the truth the left
denies objective reality and so all
they're left worth is coercion they're
just left with I I want the world to be
like this so we all have to go along
with that and if you don't go along with
that I'm gonna go into your business I'm
gonna ruin your business your livelihood
your reputation I'm gonna drag you
through the courts I'm gonna drag you
through legal proceedings for years and
years and years so in the case of Jack
Phillips this has been going on since
2012 it's been going on for six years we
as the left denies the truth and so they
have to coerce you they have to force
you what about some other what about
some other truths that the left keeps
talking about how the right is uncivil
the right is so uncivil Donald Trump is
uncivil he's unpresidential because he's
uncivil he he whips up the passions and
he is just a jerk and he calls for
violence and he's I don't know that he
really does any of that does he do that
what about the Democrats Alcee Hastings
take it away I asked the audience
tonight in Palm Beach County he said do
you know the difference between a crisis
and a catastrophe and no one held their
hand so airy answer for us he says a
crisis is if Donald Trump falls into the
Potomac River and can't swim that is
katastrophe see that's a Democrat
congressman imagine imagine if a
Republican congressman had said that
about Barack Obama a crisis as if Obama
falls in the river a catastrophe as if
anyone tries to save him imagine what
would happen do you remember there was a
rodeo clown who sort of made fun of
Obama one time some random rodeo clown
in the middle of nowhere did that it was
an international news story for weeks a
Democrat congressman is saying a
catastrophe would be if someone saves
the president from drowning and they say
he he that's that's the but the
incivility of the right but the calls to
violence the passions give me a break
yes does Donald Trump arouse passions
yeah is he uncivil yeah taken out of
context and just floating in the ether
that is a true statement but in the
context of this Democratic Party of this
left which goes out there with billy
clubs and beats up people for just
trying to go see a Ben Shapiro speech or
something in the in that context it's a
lie it's a total lie because it's the
left pushing the violence and laughing
at the violence and joking about the
violence perhaps the best example of
this is New York Times editorial board
do I have to say goodbye to Facebook I
do devastating there's so much more and
I'm gonna get to Fredo Cuomo I'm gonna
show you my favorite picture on the
internet all day and then and then I'm
gonna finally after all this talk of
incivility and lies and ignoring the
truth I'm gonna call for a little RESP
ICT but before we can get to all that I
gotta say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube you're probably already gone
because they're probably censoring us
but if not go to daily wire.com if
you're there thank you very much you
helped keep the lights on you keep
khofifah in my cup you keep Ben from
knocking down this door and firing me so
I appreciate that very much again none
of that matters we've got the
conversation coming up we're doing that
tomorrow I think aren't we that's gonna
be tomorrow I believe 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific will clarify that for you though
so you got to subscribe now so you can
ask me all the questions you want
none of that matters this is what
matters this right here the leftist
tears tumblr this is really mm-hmm oh
that's really good it's the only way to
survive these days because you've got
the left questioning the truth you've
got Rudy Giuliani joking about this on
TV says well you know when it comes to
you people the truth isn't the truth but
let me tell let me drop a little truth
on you
those leftist tears are salty and
delicious and they're going to keep
flowing so make sure you get your tumblr
we'll be right back go to daily we're
calm
all right the left is always projecting
we've talked about that and in their
projection they will say a truth which
then in context becomes a lie here's a
great example from the New York Times
Editorial Board which vicious racist
Sara Jang now sits on quote Donald Trump
the payback president the payback
president okay all right I'm with you
yeah it's pretty tough guy all right
what's it say quote what fun is it being
president if you can't use the tools of
government to punish your critics the
piece goes on there is a word for an
approach to leadership that features
treating the tax code postal rates
antitrust laws in the First Amendment as
weapons to settle one's personal grudges
and that word is not democratic it's
Obama that's the word the word is Obama
Obama esque the Obama administration I
cannot believe that they said this with
a straight face just look what are they
talking about here the payback president
first of all Barack Obama was so
vindictive against his opponents that
when the Supreme Court unjustly
redefined marriage and found a right to
intimacy or something in the
Constitution he painted the White House
in rainbow lights just to poke his
finger in the eye of his opponents but
how about this there's a word for an
approach to leadership that features
treating the tax code postal rates
antitrust laws in the first amendments
as weapons to settle one's personal
grudges Barack Obama used the IRS to
target his opponents he targeted Tea
Party groups he targeted right-wing
groups he targeted conservative leaning
organizations he added them he held them
up for years and years I know this I was
a member of the groups I was there at
the time he weaponized the IRS and maybe
the New York Times doesn't know about
that because they didn't report on it
because it was only right-wing outlets
that were talking about that ridiculous
scandal for which people had to resign
for I mean finally was enough public
pressure how about the First Amendment
using the First Amendment is a weapon
well
Barack Obama when the Supreme Court
found that you have a First Amendment
right to political speech biting down
mccain-feingold Barack Obama
couldn't respond you'd Mohnish them he
said this is terrible he lied about what
the Supreme Court decision would do
probably because he doesn't know very
much about the Constitution or
constitutional law but then to weaponize
the agency so look at what they did to
Dinesh D'Souza Dinesh D'Souza I believe
in the campaign year 2010 he gave a few
like what was a twenty or thirty
thousand dollars to wendy long his old
college pal from Dartmouth who was
running an impossible Senate race in New
York I was working newer campaigns at
the time we all knew Wendy Long was
going to lose we knew there was no
chance she was going to win and Dinesh
gave her some extra money through I
think straw donations right he seeded
the legal limit of donations to her this
happens in every campaign this happens
in every race this happens all the time
on both sides of the aisle
it is never prosecuted Barack Obama's
administration selectively prosecuted
Dinesh D'Souza and not only did they
find him for this not only did they slap
him on the wrist they threw him in the
slammer they put him in a halfway house
with murderers and rapists for six
months insane absolutely insane they
threw him there because they weaponized
the federal government to go after their
political opponents New York Times
doesn't know this so yes in the short
context is trump vindictive
you betcha is this payback for eight
years of Barack Obama running roughshod
over this country over our Constitution
over our federal government and over the
bitter clingers whom he so disdained in
the flyover country between the Pacific
and the Atlantic Ocean yes it is payback
baby and it feels good but in the
broader context Donald Trump is a
schoolboy compared to Barack Obama they
won't talk about that happen but talk
about weaponizing the government you
remember when Obama made that joke about
the Jonas Brothers yeah show that clip
from the White House Correspondents
Dinner the Jonas Brothers are here
they're out there somewhere sasha and
malia are huge fans but boys don't get
any ideas I have two words for you
Predator drones you will never see it
coming
do you think I'm joking okay I actually
kind of liked the joke I thought it was
a pretty funny joke but he's joking
about weaponizing the federal government
the reason that joke lands us because he
did that regularly he boasted in the
2012 he said I have kill lists that I
approve every morning then we kill
people some some who perhaps should have
had a trial perhaps should have had some
due process he's zapping them and of
course he weaponized the federal
government against his political
opponents to that's why it landed okay
before we go I know we're running at a
time I do want to point out the most
Orwellian version of this so you can all
be on your toes about it I previously
I've been referring to Chris is fredo
Cuomo but I think Andrew might be I
think they're all Fredo it's a family of
Fredo's you know they're no there's not
even a sunny there's certainly no
Michael it's just all frado's in the
Cuomo family Mario included Mario is
know Vito let me tell you he is if
people say Mario Cuomo would be so
ashamed of his sons no he wouldn't Mario
was a total degenerate too he was the
guy who pioneered I'm pro-life but I
oppose but I support abortion I said
what he goes I'm personally pro-life but
I support legal abortion and killing
babies that doesn't make any sense Mario
he's the guy who pioneered that a family
of degenerates the Cuomo's anyway so
andrew Cuomo is now accusing Donald
Trump of being anti-american that's the
phrase anti-american this is Andrew
Cuomo last week we're not gonna make
America great again it was ever that
great we have not reached greatness we
will reach greatness when every American
is fully engaged
so the guy who says America is not great
we're not gonna make America great again
America was never that great that guy is
accusing Donald Trump who whose entire
campaign is to make America great again
and constantly extol the virtues of
America to call him anti-american does
it get more Orwellian than that that
that is what Orwellian ISM is so when
you see the left say Oh Giuliani is
being Orwellian he's saying truth isn't
truth give me a break
like we could go on I'm running out of
time so we can't keep going on with
these examples you could go all day
showing these examples from the left
it's so it's so outrageous but they
should they say look he said that yeah
all shallows are clear in a very narrow
context the left get out of context
rather the left can say true things in
context they're dirty rotten liars now
this brings me to this is America very
quickly
I can't help it post this it's the
greatest image on the Internet all week
in the last few weeks it's Nancy Pelosi
holding an American flag have you ever
seen a person look less comfortable
doing anything it's just they're like
aah
get it away I'm gonna melt if it are it
burns it burns the America was never
that great I'm gonna make it my desktop
background that photo is beautiful I
don't know why she would allow herself
to be photographed with the American
flag as its as its radiating off of her
like kryptonite but really really good
before we go on a quick little segment
that I would like to refer to as how to
be a man when you look like a Maddow we
have to talk about exclamation points we
have to talk about it The Wall Street
Journal and we think about this over the
weekend because they ran this piece
called the tyranny of the exclamation
point is causing email and text anxiety
when I talk to people who are serious
people and serious thinkers almost
uniformly they complain about the
prevalence of exclamation points you
know this every text is an exclamation
point every email is like 20 exclamation
points you have to do it as though
everyone is just like blowing lines of
cofee
and it's just constantly well maybe I am
okay I can use exclamation points but no
but other people shouldn't because it's
too much man it's too much some of the
greatest riders in history have despised
exclamation points f scott Fitzgerald
has a good one he says quote cut out all
these exclamation points an exclamation
point is like laughing at your own joke
and that is what it is your your cueing
the audience or the recipient to that
you've had a joke and they should laugh
it's like a laugh track in a sitcom you
have to do it because the strength of
your language didn't make them laugh
Mark Twain said the same thing he said
it's like laughing at your own humor
quote all of which is very depressing
and makes one want to renounce joking
and lead a better life that is true you
get all these emails and one thing I'll
notice too I'm as guilty of this as
anybody I use exclamation points and
emails and I have to stop doing it and
you should too because when you get an
email from someone who doesn't use
exclamation points you just respect them
more because you know that they're more
serious they're more confident the use
of exclamation points shows that you're
not very confident in your joke or in
your statement or in the relationship or
whatever it shows it creates anxiety
what the wall street journal is talking
about is now if you get an email without
an exclamation point you think Oh am I
getting fired if I if the god-king sends
me an email and there aren't 15
exclamation points and I know I'm fired
they're finally gonna kick the door in
then it's gonna drag me out of here
kicking and screaming this gets back to
this David McCullough's line which is
that - right well as to think clearly
which is why it's so hard if you are
telling a joke or trying to convey
something amusing we're trying to
exclaim something trying to convey
something particularly important in a
particularly emphatically you should do
it with words you should use your words
carefully
we don't use words very well anymore and
so now there are misspellings we type in
text speak in all of this and we make up
for that with the stupid punctuation and
these exclamation points very unmanly
take it from a guy like me okay
I'm got these horn-rimmed - rachel
maddow glasses on you know I'm not
exactly a giant or an Olympian or
something I've got to find masculinity
where I can where I can access it and
this is one simple way that everybody
can
do it you you too right well as to think
clearly cut it out with those
exclamation points we'll all calm down
you know one of the complaints about our
civil society today is everyone so
worked up and frenzied all the time and
you know crazy decrease just you don't
have to get rid of them entirely just
bring them back I think one way you can
use them is ha exclamation point
you know me ha that's because you are
laughing in the huh you know or if
you're trying to be sarcastic you can
use an exclamation point but in your own
earnest writing just a comment down I'm
gonna work to comment down on Twitter on
email maybe you should too will have a
more relaxed confident society and will
finally respect ourselves again you know
so much of is we don't really respect
ourselves and our own ideas and so in
the words of my late friend Aretha
Franklin and show some RESP ICT that's
right that's exactly right Reverend
Sharpton you've got to respect yourself
some more because the you know the
journal made me think about it a little
bit but it's really you Reverend
Sharpton you may realize you've got to
just respect yourself like in the words
of Aretha Franklin or ESP I see tea
period not exclamation point come back
tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt gym is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018